one of the things that museums have been
on the vanguard for for the last hundred
years is the discussion the public
discussion of evolution and specifically
the evolution of humans and for clearly
since Darwin's time its that was one of
the great discoveries was that humans
actually are descendants from other
forms of animals and we are part of the
Tree of Life we are not separate from
the Tree of Life we are part of the Tree
of Life and we've watched that the 20th
century this continuous addition of
information to that narrative and now we
have with the with the genome the human
genome project we have the ultimate tool
for mapping our position in the rest of
the Tree of Life so it's sort of like in
many ways that the final nail in the
building of understanding how we fit
with the rest of the things that live on
this planet I think it's really
important that people do understand that
evolution is what makes biology make
sense
it's what makes all life makes sense so
from the museum point of view it's
always been a very important thing to
show the actual evidence for evolution
so if you don't have a rational
conversation about evolution and
creationism and I have had many rational
conversations with creationists who
often feel that they haven't seen the
evidence for evolution and museums again
are the most accessible portal for
understanding science that we have and
museums by presenting dinosaur skeletons
and exhibits about human evolution frame
the evidence that we have the
three-dimensional evidence we have for
evolution and I found that be the most
powerful way is to walk through an
exhibit and say here are the elements of
evolution manifests because frankly
evolution is not an obvious or intuitive
concept it was an amazing discovery that
we're all related but it was not obvious
it's not obvious that I'm related to a
strawberry
but that's the story of evolution